>> Tucker: SO YOU MAY HAVE READ
IN THE NEWS THAT JOE BIDEN JUST
MADE AMERICA A LITTLE BETTER BY
SIGNING THE SPEAK OUT ACT INTO
LAW.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO COMBAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
WHAT YOU DIDN'T READ IS THAT JOE
BIDEN HIMSELF HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT INCLUDING HIS OWN
DAUGHTER WHOM HE SHOWERED WITH.
TARA REID WHILE WORKING FOR JOE
BIDEN IN THE U.S. SENATE, HE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED HER IN A
VIOLENT WAY.
MOST OF THE MEDIA BURIED THE
STORY.
I'LL HAVE TO BE HONEST, I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO THINK OF IT.
BUT WE TALKED AT GREAT LENGTH
WITH TARA REID TO HEAR WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE WERE COMPLETELY CONVINCED
THIS IS REAL AND SHE WAS ABLE TO
PROVE IT.
THE WHOLE STORY IS PART OF A NEW
STORY "TUCKER CARLSON TODAY."
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> HE STARTED ACTING WEIRD
TOWARDS ME.
HE WOULD PUS HIS HAND ON MY
SHOULDER AND PUT HIS HANDS UNDER
MY HAIR.
THERE WAS A SCENE --
>> Tucker: WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THAT?
>> BEAR IN MIND, YOU WERE AROUND
AND A PROFESSIONAL IN THE 90s.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE IN
D.C. --
>> Tucker: I WAS IN D.C.
>> IT WAS A DIFFERENT VIBE.
IT WAS STILL WE'RE.
PANETTA DIDN'T ACT LIKE THAT.
HE'S ALL BUSINESS.
JOE BIDEN WAS ALWAYS -- HE
DIDN'T SEED LIKE AN
INTELLECTUALLY GIANT.
>> Tucker: YES, BUT A WARM GUY.
>> YEAH.
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, HE WAS VERY
TEMPERAMENTAL.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> HE WOULD DO THIS THING WHERE
HE SMILES WHEN HE'S ANGRY.
IT'S DISCONCERTING.
THAT BIG SMILE.
YOU KNOW, HE WOULD BE ANGRY.
VERY TEMPERAMENTAL.
HE HAD ME UP AGAINST A WALL.
HE PENETRATED ME WITH HIS
FINGERS AGAINST MY WILL.
AND I -- YOU KNOW, IT WAS -- IT
WASN'T JUST THE ASSAULT THOUGH.
IT WAS JUST -- IT WAS EVERYTHING
TO DO WITH HEAR I AM, THIS YOUNG
STAFFER AND HE DID THIS.
AND THEN I MADE HIM ANGRY.
THAT'S LIKE SOMEONE YOU DON'T
WANT TO MAKE ANGRY.
BECAUSE I SAID NO.
>> Tucker: I GOT TO BE HONEST,
ONE OF THE REASONS I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO MAKE OF YOUR STORY IS
BECAUSE IT'S SO -- I'VE BEEN A
MAN 53 YEARS.
I NEVER HEARD OF ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT IS LIKE -- MEN ARE PIGGISH
AS WE KNOW.
THEY DO PIGGISH THINGS.
THAT'S LIKE KIND OF LIKE RAPE.
THAT IS SO OUT OF BOUNDS THAT
IT'S WEIRD TO THINK SOMEONE
WOULD DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> IT WAS JUST -- IT HAPPENED
ALL AT ONCE.
IT HAPPENED REALLY QUICKLY.
THERE WAS NO FLIRTATION WITH
HIM.
IT WAS VERY -- HE WAS USUALLY
WITH PEOPLE AND HE WASN'T.
I WAS LIKE AT THE WRONG PLACE,
THE WRONG TIME SO TO SPEAK.
WHEN IT HAPPENED, HE AT FIRST
WAS LIKE COME ON, MAN.
I HEARD YOU LIKED ME.
AND I FROZE.
THEN HE SAID HE GOT ANGRY AND
THAT'S WHEN HE SMILED THAT
SMILE.
THAT'S WHAT WAS REALLY JARRING.
AND THEN HE POINTED HIS FINGER
IN MY FACE AND HE SAID YOU'RE
NOTHING.
YOU'RE NOTHING TO ME.
THEN I MUST HAVE HAD A CERTAIN
LOOK ON MY FACE AND HE TOOK MY
SHOULDERS AND HE SAID YOU'RE
FINE, YOU'RE FINE.
HE TURNED AROUND AND HE WALKED
AWAY.
AND I REMEMBER IT WAS JUST SUCH
A JARRING SHOCKING INCIDENT.
PROBABLY LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE MY VIVID MEMORY IS
SITTING ON THESE MARBLE STAIRS
AND MY LEGS WERE SHAKING SO
BADLY BECAUSEN'T JUST WHAT HE
DID.
I KNEW MY CAREER WAS OVER.
THAT WAS IT.
I HAD SAID NO.
IT WAS AN AWFUL THING.
THIS WAS THE END.
HE USED HIS POWER AND RESOURCES
TO SILENCE ME.
I'M GOING TO SHARE SOMETHING
WITH YOUR AUDIENCE.
THEY TOOK A CANNON BALL TO MY
LIFE.
THEY WENT AFTER MY FAMILY.
SO WHEN THAT DAY -- WHEN HE DID
THAT ASSAULT, HE TOOK MY FUTURE.
I DIDN'T WANT TO SLEEP WITH SOME
SENATOR.
I WANTED TO BE ONE.
THAT DAY IT ENDED.
>> Tucker: THE CRUELTY SHE
DESCRIBES.
NOT JUST AN UNWANTED ADVANCE,
NOT JUST THE SEXUAL VIOLENCE BUT
THE MEANNESS TO HER FROM JOE
BIDEN AND FROM HIS STAFF AND
FROM PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL BLOW YOUR
MIND.
REALLY OFFENSIVE TO ANYBODY.
NOT ON PARTISAN GROUNDS.
THIS IS A HUMAN BEING.
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE PEOPLE WOULD
ACT THAT WAY.
WE CALLED THE WHITE HOUSE HAND
ASKED US FOR COMMENT F